TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
How's everybody doing?
Hi.
So thanks for coming
to this session.
It is an introduction
to the +1 button.
If that's what you're here for,
you're in the right room.
If it's not what you're here
for, you're in the wrong room.
These are some bits of
information that you might be
interested in.
There's a hashtag for
this session,
#publisher and #io2011.
And there's also a link for
feedback about this session.
I'd love to hear
what you think.
And there's also a link for
where this session is going to
live after today.
All right.
So this is what we're
going to talk about.
We're going to talk about
the +1 button.
And, specifically, up top is
what's now, which is the +1
button on search.
Then we're going to talk about
the +1 button on your site.
That's what's next.
We going to go through getting
started, some advanced
options, and optimization.
And, of course, at the
end, I will answer
some of your questions.
Please note that the +1 button
on your site is not yet
launched and will not
be launching today.
But I'm giving you a first peek
about what that'll look
like, and how you'll be able to
integrate it on your site.
Sound good?
All right.
Now, I'd also like to say that
integrating the +1 button on
your site is super easy,
so this is going
to go pretty quick.
This is me.
I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google.
And you can find me online.
Also feel free to
at mention me.
All right.
So let's start with
what's now.
I'm going to give a little bit
of background around the +1
button, and why we decided
to create it.
There are a couple different
sharing methods that we looked
at out there in the world.
One of them is email.
I think we're all familiar
with email, right?
It's an interesting
medium because it
is super high value.
When you write an email to
somebody, they receive that
personal information from you
and that personal endorsement,
but it's also really
high effort.
It takes some time to write
names in that to field and
craft a message just
to those people.
So there's another way to share,
activity streams. And
this is also really common.
It's super easy to share to an
activity stream, very, very
low effort.
But, in general, for
endorsements,
it's pretty low value.
It's great for breaking news
or sharing funny videos.
Things that aren't time
sensitive or time specific.
But when I am looking for a
toaster oven, I may not have
seen this message because
perhaps Cami Crepe
wrote it a month ago.
So when those things match up,
it's like magic, but it hardly
ever happens.
So we've got this one method
that's low effort and
relatively low value
for endorsements.
And we've got this other method
that's really, really
high value, but also
high effort.
How do we put the two together
so that we have something
that's low effort, but also
really high value?
And that, of course,
is the +1.
So let's take a look at this.
You can do this on your own.
You can play the home
game by going to
google.com/experimental and
opting it into the search
experiment.
And you'll start to see +1
buttons on your search results
page right away.
And this is what it
will look like.
I did a quick search
for King day books.
And I got this great article
by The Huffington Post on
books that I could read to
commemorate Martin Luther
King, Jr. Day.
This is as you expect.
It's a search engine results
page with links and snippets.
And there's now a +1 button
just to the right.
Wonder if I have a
laser pointer.
Ooh, I do.
They're fun.
So that +1 button is
what you'd hit
to take the +1 action.
But there's this other new
thing, and this is the value.
It's that annotation right
below the result.
Say you're looking for the
same search results--
you're doing the same search.
And you come upon this page, and
you see this annotation.
Your good buddy Timothy
recommending
that article for you.
Notice how it looks different
than every other
result on that page.
I got some numbers too.
It turns out 90% of consumers
trust recommendations from
their friends.
And 71% say friends and family
influence their purchase
decisions online.
So we know that these
annotations are really
powerful, and they make your
results stand out.
So it's super high
value, right?
It's also super low effort.
It is one single button.
And it's just one click,
and you add your
recommendation to that link.
And it looks like that.
It just lights up,
and you're done.
Pretty cool, huh?
Oops.
It's also available
on paid results.
So you'll see on the ad here, we
also got a +1 button and an
annotation under that.
Now we think these annotations
are going to be great, that
they may increase CTR, your
clickthrough rate, on both
paid and organic listings.
And something publishers tell us
time and time again is that
traffic from google.com is
typically more valuable.
It spends more time on
their site, and it is
more likely to convert.
And we think that that's going
to even increase with the +1
button as the user not only
comes from this unique place
on the internet, but also
with a recommendation.
Cool.
So that's the +1 button.
Many of you may have
seen that already.
Let's talk about what's next.
+1 button on your site.
So I followed that link, and
this is the page that I got.
It's The Huffington Post page,
but you'll notice there's
something new.
Down there by all the sharing
links, you'll see a +1 button.
It's off in the lower right.
Yeah.
Clicking this button is easy.
It's just a button click.
The count increments, and
you've added your
recommendation to this page.
Now why would a button need to
be on the website as well?
Well it turns out we've gotten
a lot of feedback from people
after we introduced this search
experiment that they
might not know that they want
to add their endorsement to
something when they're in the
search engine results page.
But when they go to your site,
and they see what it's all
about, then they're maybe
more likely to
click that +1 button.
And the great thing about this
is that on this search engine
results page you may have
clicked on an organic result,
I may have clicked on a paid
result, and Rebecca may have
clicked on your site, and
it all goes to the same
annotation.
So let's do some stuff,
shall we?
It's a developer conference.
How about we look
at some code?
I'm afraid there's not
a lot to look at
because it's super simple.
We've got two tags.
We've got a script tag right
up there at the top, just
includes the script that's
going to replace the
tags on your page.
And we've got the +1 tag.
And it looks like this.
Using all the default options,
we don't need to add any
attributes.
And that tag will just
get replaced by the
script with a button.
There's also going to be an
HTML5 equivalent to this tag
so that you'll be able to
validate your pages easier.
This is what a basic
page looks like.
Yeah, same script, but we've
added the surrounding tags
that are on the page.
Of particular interest up at the
top is the rel canonical.
Put this here for a
couple of reasons.
First off, you're probably
already using rel canonical.
Actually, I'm a little curious,
who is using rel
canonical in the audience?
All right.
Who's not using rel canonical?
That should be everybody else
raising their hands.
Or maybe you're too
embarrassed to.
You really should be using
real canonical because it
tells Google what the true URL
of your page is, which often
differs from the address
in the address bar.
The address in the address
bar often has
state variables, right?
You get that question mark,
state equals something or
other, that don't actually
represent the true URL, but
are difficult to strip out.
So you can tell Google what is
the true URL of this page by
specifying rel canonical.
And you get to tell the +1
button what URL it should +1.
And then, of course, here's
that script again.
So let's take a look at this.
I have a cool thing
to show you.
I'm super excited about.
This is a prototype of our +1
Button Configuration Tool.
And when we launch, you'll be
able to go to this tool and
configure a +1 button
for yourself.
This is how it works.
See the +1 button?
Boom.
Now it comes in a number of
different sizes, and you'll
see down here is the script.
In my example, I included the
script and the tag together,
but you probably want to put the
script somewhere else like
in your head or right before
the body closes.
And it has the +1 tag.
And you'll notice, even as I add
these options-- and I'll
go through these in some more
detail --even as I add these
options, the snippet stays
really, really simple.
It can even do things like
pull away the count.
And add the count back in.
It's fun.
So that's that.
Let's get back, and let's dive
a little bit deeper into some
of those advanced options,
shall we?
First off, +1s are for URLs.
And it's got to be
a public URL.
Otherwise, it's not
going to work.
+1s are a public action,
so they need to
operate on public URLs.
And the URL is determined by
one of three things and in
this order.
First, we're going to
look at the href
attribute of the +1 tag.
If it's there, we're going
to +1 that URL.
And you would use this attribute
if say, let's say
you're on a blog home page,
and you've got several
different articles.
And you want to put a
+1 button by each
one of those articles.
And that +1 button should +1
the URL of that article.
You would specify that
URL in the href tag.
The next thing that we look
for is rel canonical.
I've already talked
about that.
And then the third thing we
look for is the URL of the
page as you would see
in the address bar,
document.location.href.
And, of course, we much prefer
rel canonical over this
because, again, it might
not represent the
true URL of the page.
And it would be sad to have some
of your users +1 their
particular URL, and other users
+1 their particular URL,
and they look like
different +1s.
So rel canonical is good.
All right.
I got a table because tables
are important.
This is a table of +1 buttons.
As you can see, we
have a number of
different form factors.
We've got small.
We've got medium.
We've got standard.
And they all come with
or without a count.
And we've got the tall button.
And standard, of course, is a
really common size that fits
among other buttons of
similar sharing type.
All right.
Size and count are as
what you'd expect.
They get to specify what the
size is, and whether or not it
has a count.
And then we have two other
attributes here. href I've
already talked about.
Callback I haven't.
We're going to provide a
callback so that when the user
hits the +1 button, a function
in the global JavaScript
namespace on your page
can be called.
And this could be
really great.
Because perhaps you have
identity on your page, a user
is already logged in.
You can perhaps track their
+1s on your site to their
identity and maybe use that to
improve their experience.
All right.
Here are some parameters
for the script tag.
And we've got two.
First off is language.
You'll be able to specify other
languages for the button.
The second one is parse tags.
Now this gets a little
bit more interesting.
By default, it's onload.
So all the tags will be parsed
at onload of the page.
But you can also specify
explicit, which means you get
to specify when those
tags get parsed.
And you can do that
one of two ways.
The most common way you would
do this is with .go.
And .go takes a single
parameter.
That parameter is some
ID of a container.
Now what you might use this for
is let's say you have a
really large page, but your +1
buttons are only maybe in the
article div.
Then you can specify the article
div, and the script
will only scan through
that content.
The script will have to
scan less content.
And it will run faster.
You might also do this if you
don't want the buttons loaded
onload, you want them maybe
a few seconds after.
Maybe your page has some fancy
performance stuff that that
makes more sense.
The second way you would use
this explicit parse tag is
through render.
And you would do this
typically if you
had an Ajax-y page.
Let's say the user switched the
content on the page, but
didn't reload a page
in their browser.
And you needed to put a
new +1 button there.
You could use the render method
that would then render
the +1 button in the specified
container with those specified
parameters.
You don't need a +1 tag.
So let's take a look at
a couple examples.
This is the explicit load.
And you'll see on here I've
highlighted both the script up
at the top, which includes
the +1 script.
And down there we have the basic
+1 tag that specifies
where the button should go.
And then below there, I just
added a script, and I hit .go.
And this would work.
Obviously, this is not
a perfect example.
It's a basic example.
You would probably want this .go
in an onload handler, and
you want to specify a subdiv.
And here's another example.
This is using render.
Notice that the +1 tag
is not on the page.
Instead, I have a div, called
the plusone-div there, down
third line from the bottom.
And I have an onload specified
in the body tag.
That function calls the
.render on that div.
Default options, totally
works great.
Does this all make sense?
You guys are so easy.
I don't know if that's because
it makes sense, or if you're
all using your new tablets.
I hope it's because it
all makes sense.
All right.
Let's talk a little bit
about optimization.
And this is all about improving
your traffic and
your engagement on the site.
And to do that, you need to
be able to measure it and
experiment.
And you got to try different
things to make it better.
So we'd like to provide data to
you to be able to do that.
Now I'm going to show you some
early product mocks.
It'll probably look different.
But this will give you an
indication of where we're
going with something inside of
Webmaster Tools that will give
you data on the +1 button.
First off, we have activity.
We'd like to be able to provide
to you a page that
shows how often your
content had been
+1'd and on what pages.
Pretty straightforward
and cool-looking.
Search impact.
This is going to tell you the
difference in clickthrough
rate for annotated results and
non-annotated results.
So you'll really be able to see
the power and value of the
+1 button on your site.
We'd also like to provide
anonymized user data, such as
unique users and geo, where
in the world these
+1s are coming from.
All right.
I have a summary slide.
Told you it was quick.
Social connections may very well
increase CTR on both paid
and organic search listings.
When users see that annotation,
we think they may
be more likely to click that
result than any other.
And research shows that
that's probably true.
Search traffic is pre-qualified
through personal
recommendations.
So remember, publishers tell
us traffic from google.com
often converts more than traffic
from other sources.
Add in a recommendation from
my father to that, and I'm
much more likely to convert.
The +1 button on your site--
oops --the +1 button on your
site gives your users more
opportunity to click.
And that +1 from an organic
result, from a paid result or
from your site all goes to the
same annotation on search.
And, finally, integration is
straightforward and flexible.
So what do you do next?
First thing you can do
is go to this form,
google.com/webmasters/+1button,
and put down your name.
And we'll send you an email as
soon as this is available.
And you can also go ahead
and take a look at the
+1 button on search.
You can click a whole bunch of
stuff and see how fun it is--
google.com/experimental.
All right.
So it was quick, a little
quicker than I expected, but I
hope it was fun.
The hashtags, feedback,
and session are there.
We have microphones
there and there.
And I would love to hear your
questions and perhaps feedback
on this product.
AUDIENCE: Can you move
that slide back?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: That slide.
Could you move it back to the
one you had previously?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, sure.
And go.
There we are.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, could
you use the microphone?
I am told today my biggest
audience is the internet.
And that means that you
need to use the
microphone to ask a question.
AUDIENCE: I see that it's
all done in JavaScript.
It seems like that would be
pretty easy to hack where
somebody could write a little
script where every visit +1
the page, or they could write
a script that gives them a
million +1s or something
like that.
What is Google doing
to prevent that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: A lot.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I mean,
yeah, it's a concern.
Abuse with any new feature
is a concern.
And it's something that we're
taking seriously.
And we are engineering
solutions for.
What those specific solutions
are, I'm going to keep to
those engineers.
AUDIENCE: And then the second
one was, it said names of
people that had +1'd that.
Those are just people that are
in your gmail group or
something like that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a great question.
So the people that appear on
annotations for you are folks
that are in your contacts, your
Google contacts, which
could be your gmail contacts,
any connected sites you've
connected to your profile, and
any publicly-available social
graph data that we can correlate
with your identity.
AUDIENCE: And the last question
is, would there be an
opportunity to put a +1 external
to your site, say in
your emails or on another
related page or
something where it--
I could see someone can +1 right
out of the Google search
results or off your page, but
would there be a way to +1 say
off of emails you send
or related pages?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's an
interesting question.
I'm not sure what we're doing
about cross-domain +1s, which
I think sort of addresses
that question.
I don't have an answer for you
on that, but I'm sure we'll
have an answer soon.
The interesting thing about
email though is because email
typically, even HTML emails,
don't allow JavaScript.
So even if you could put the +1
in an HTML email, most user
agents aren't going to be able
to render that button.
But I think it is an interesting
use case to have
that +1 button on a variety
of different sources.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
One quick question.
Does the API allow the site to
read the count information?
Or is that something
you frame?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That is
a very good question.
At launch, we are going to have
a button that will have
the count in there.
We may add that feature
in the future.
AUDIENCE: But is the information
framed or can my
site also read-- if I have
access to the DOM, can I read
the account?
Or are you guys creating your
own iframe and generating the
count and the button
in a frame?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I suspect since
the count is in the
button, and it's in an
iframe that you could
do something fancy.
But I think it would be more
interesting if that was
something that you really wanted
to let us know on the
Webmaster Forum, and perhaps
we could engineer a more
convenient way for
you to do that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
More social plug-ins and things
like this coming out
afterwards for people
that want to have--
be able to surface content that
I've been the most +1'd
and things like this?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I would
definitely be interested in
hearing more about specifically
those kind of
widgets that you would want.
And perhaps.
Yeah, that could be cool.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And let's
go over here.
Yeah.
I won't forget about that
side of the room.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Actually, my question is
more related to search.
It looks like you guys have it
set up as kind of a social
construct right now.
Do you have any plans to
integrate it with the
algorithm as far as the
actual ranking of
the sites is concerned?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
So +1s may be a signal that
we use in ranking.
AUDIENCE: That's cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And it would
be among over 250 other
signals that we use
in ranking.
AUDIENCE: I think
that covers it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm going to go
back to this just in case
you need to live tweet
any of this.
Yes.
Let's take another one
over there, and
we'll come back here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
How does the +1 sign operate
when the user
hasn't logged in?
What does it do when there's
no Google account?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
So a user does need a
Google account and a
public profile for +1s.
It's a public action, so they
need to be able to have their
name publicly available.
And if the user is not signed
in, it'll ask them to sign in.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's a very simple sign-in flow,
and a simple onboarding
flow as well.
AUDIENCE: So using your +1,
you care about different
people's influences you said.
You care a lot more for your
dad if he has his +1--
he gave you a +1 versus one of
your contacts that's way--
you don't really
talk to a lot.
Is there any way to prioritize
which people are given +1s?
Like if you have five people you
really care about that if
they've given a +1, it's
more influential?
Can you pick and have
them added?
Like, I want these five people
always if they've given a +1
to show up.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a great point.
And I think it's something
that we've thought about.
And obviously, we'd want to show
annotations that matter
the most to the user, right?
And there's sort of two
things in there.
One is that we're not going to
show annotations for every
result on the page, right?
So we're only going to show
them for the results that
should matter to the user.
And, hopefully, the personal
invitations, we get that so
that that's the contact that
matters the most to the user.
And we'll use the data that
we have available
to try and do that.
So you want to go to
the microphone?
I would love to hear
your question.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When do we get it?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: When?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: When
do you get it?
I was waiting for
that question.
In a matter of weeks.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And you shared on The Huffington
Post site, did you
just mock that up, or they
actually tested it?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
mocked that up.
I took that into Photoshop, and
I did fun things with it.
Do you like it?
AUDIENCE: I like it
better on my site.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Feel
free to tell them.
Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned callback
functionality and
that sort of thing.
With social connections, are
we, as developers, going to
have any sort of access to that
on our site to show if
you're on a page, hey, your
dad liked this story.
Or even broader to have an
actual page to say here's what
your friends liked on my site,
that sort of thing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So at launch
what you'll see is the
aggregate annotation,
which is the count.
Right?
And we think that's powerful
for users.
If there are other things that
you'd like to see, like, if
you'd like to see personal
annotations on your site, then
we'd definitely like
to hear that.
So Webmaster Tools Forum
would be a great
place to mention that.
But, of course, I'll
remember as well.
Thank you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So hey, this looks a
little similar to the Like
button on Facebook.
So I'm just curious, what
are the pros and cons?
How does it compare
in your view?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
That's a good question.
How is the +1 different
than the Like button
that Facebook has?
And I can't speak
for Facebook.
But I can speak for my personal
view of this.
Yeah.
And I think when I use the Like
button on the web, I like
things that I want to be
part of my identity.
Right?
Because, typically, that shows
up on my Facebook profile.
And I love that.
When I +1 something, I get to
+1 anything that I like that
I'm publicly OK with saying,
this is cool.
But it doesn't have to
be part of who I am.
So that's how I would categorize
the difference in
my use case.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what are you doing
to differentiate this
from say the Buzz launch?
Because I can see a
public reaction to
the names that appear.
It seems a little similar.
And I'm just wondering what
your sort of PR stance is
going to be, et cetera.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I can't speak
to the Buzz launch.
But what I can say about the
names that I think might
interest you is that when we
onboard the user, we're going
to indicate to them clearly
that their +1s
are a public action.
So when you +1 something,
the whole world gets
to know about it.
Don't +1 something that you
don't want the world to know.
And as long as you empowered
by that, there's less of a
concern hopefully.
Also, the understanding that
when they see annotations in
search, they're seeing
annotations from people on
their contacts.
So it'll be another indication
to the user that this is a
public action.
AUDIENCE: And you said this is
different than logging in.
So you have to have a
public page then?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you need to
have a public profile, a
public Google profile.
And if you don't want to have a
public Google profile, then
you don't have to
use the button.
But if you want to use the
button, then you agree to have
a public profile and have
your name publicly
associated with those +1s.
AUDIENCE: And have you gotten
any sense of what the opt-in
rate will be for users?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hopefully,
fantastic.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, how
do you un-+1?
Let's say, you +1 on something
and you thought, oh, no, I
don't really want to do that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I was waiting
for that question too.
There's all these ones
that I'm waiting for.
So when you +1, you
hit the button.
When you un-+1, you
Isn't that great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So then you have to
hit the +1 twice?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh no.
So when you hit the
button, it +1's.
If you hit it again,
it'll undo that +1.
DAN: [INAUDIBLE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
So when you hit the button,
it'll turn blue.
And when you hit it again to
un-+1, it'll go back to its
rest state where you see it.
Thank you, Dan.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why do you have to
have a public profile and will
your +1s show up on your
public profile?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So since it's
a public action, and you're
associating your public name
with the +1 button, you need
to have that name be public.
You don't have to have
this public profile.
the profile.
But if you want to +1s, your
name needs to be public.
It's the whole value.
As far as on your profile, you
can opt in to have a tab on
your profile of all your +1s.
And you can actually take a
look at how this is today.
If you go to
google.com/experimental, and
you sign into the search
experiment.
And you can go to your
profile, and you can
opt into that tap.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And was the thought of your
having to have a public
profile just one more signal
that when you +1, you're doing
something publicly?
Or is there more to
it than that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, part of
having a public profile is
having a public name.
And part of doing a public +1
is having a public name.
So they all require
each other.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to add a -1 button?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: None
that I know of.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Since it'll take time
for the +1 button to roll
out across several web pages,
are there any plans to
directly integrate the +1 button
with the Chrome browser
instead of the web
page itself?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
a really cool idea.
I will take that back.
So give me your idea, just a
little bit more detail, you'd
like the +1 button where?
AUDIENCE: Right, like
as an extension
on the Chrome browser.
So that if you go to a site that
isn't regularly updated
or doesn't have a lot of social
networking widgets
already built in, you could +1
it without the web author
having previously coded it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I
don't have anything
to say about that.
But I think it's a cool idea.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is that it?
Those are all the questions?
I feel so successful.
All right.
Well, thank you all so
much for coming in.
If you'd like to ask a question
of me privately after
the session, I'll be hanging
out for a few minutes,
probably at least 30 of them.
Thank you so much.